we got this from timcast.com
the daily wire has received about 200
violations from YouTube regarding
coverage of transgenderism Jeremy boring
quote YouTube only does more damage the
longer it keeps its finger on the scales
Candace Owens and Michael Knowles have
both been suspended for seven days from
Friday well they were they were
suspended completely suspended
completely cannot post videos I didn't
realize that and and well funny enough
no one's writing about it wow yeah if
you look it up it'll just say
demonetized but Jeremy Moore Jeremy
Jeremy boring Jeremy Jeremy says on
Friday Candace Owens and Michael Knowles
were suspended for seven days after
receiving their second strike and Jordan
Peterson was given his first strike
three in 90 days and your account is
terminated I don't think this has
anything to do with the Trans issue to
be completely honest I think what we're
seeing with Fox News with project
Veritas and now the daily wire anybody
who is prominent and vocal and is a
threat to the establishment is starting
to get hit particularly hard kind of
like DDOS attacks over at the
post-millennial and human events where
if you go and subscribe you can help us
prevent but but in all seriousness yes
post-millennial bongino report human
events just got hit as we're preparing
to do this show with a major DDOS attack
it's all coordinated there's no way
look you know we had on
um I think it was John cardello and we
were talking about Veritas and I said I
find it very strange that Fox News and
veritas did basically the same thing to
O'Keefe and Tucker suspend them so they
can't work but don't release them from
their contracts yes so they can't go
anywhere else either that's a very
specific strategy to take against
prominent individuals in the cultural
debate in the culture War as for the
daily wire they're not big Trump guys
you know they're they're many of their
personnel's are very much for Ron
DeSantis but either way they're
challenging the cultural establishment
the norms and the Machine and so what
they're saying is that YouTube is
actively employs YouTube are actively
going through year-old videos and
issuing strikes and takedowns for posts
that they had no problem with before
wait so this isn't like this isn't like
the daily one and I'm sorry I haven't
read the story but this isn't like the
daily wire launched some new campaign
that broke all the rules it's that the
rules have actually shifted and they're
going retroactively yes against old
videos that were okay which by the way
YouTube recently changed the rules
regarding elections so there was there
was a certain topic that we could only
talk about here on in the third hour
which we could now talk about on the
radio show that's actually not
necessarily true we we I I talked with
Steve Bannon about the election issue
and he outright said he thought the
election was stolen they just had this
weird rule that I think only applied to
YouTube's rules only apply to their
actual targets and the rules are
arbitrary is the easiest way to put it I
mean that's what I'm getting at the when
when uh the hill I think it was the hill
Rising I I believe uh with uh Sagar and
crystal ball Sagar and Jetty and crystal
ball they had a clip I think it was them
I could be wrong they had a clip of
Donald Trump at a rally because they
don't do it anymore and then Donald
Trump at the rally said the election was
stolen and YouTube took their video down
there were also like news reports where
they did the same thing but then you had
David pakman who had on Mike Lindell and
David allowed Mike Lindell to say
his entire theory of how the election
was stolen and I asked YouTube why is it
that David Pacman can host Mike Lindell
and say Mike tell us all tell us
everything and then he does but then you
take down a clip from a rally that was
on the news of Donald Trump saying a
thing it's because the rules were
arbitrary as they are now YouTube didn't
change their rules on transgenders and
they're changing their interpretation of
what breaks the rules that's what
they're doing so if you know Matt Walsh
or Michael Knowles and Michael Knowles
especially makes a very simple and
academic argument about his views on
transgenderism or something like that
they that they'll say okay well that
didn't cross the line
year later you know what nah it did boom
because what is hate speech it's
interpretable there's no clearly defined
line that you can or cannot cross it's
just uh you're against it sustained
speech take you down I think this is a
lot to do with the election cycle is
here don't be surprised if they start
coming at us in some way somehow
whatever that may be they're already
coming after you whoever who and I'm
talking about and we're gonna literally
we're gonna dig into this I'm talking
about super pac's political interests uh
hackers probably Rogue elements of the
Intel agencies we've already seen by uh
foreign States foreign States I mean if
Ukraine's involved in this obviously
they don't want these tapes coming out
have you not experienced the retroactive
your episode Brandon there was that the
episode
I wasn't on that episode what happened
yeah don't know the app the the last
time you were here we we did an episode
and one of the clips was was removed and
your full episode was removed I believe
the clip came from the full episode and
we got an email from YouTube saying we
know that you didn't intend to break the
rules but you did so we were moving
these videos but not applying a strike
to your channel and then the video was
taken down wait wait have you seen have
you seen what Darren Beatty's been
talking about about his clips from from
here
so IRL from IRL where and I'd have to go
back and look exactly what it was but
they he had a clip from IRL from like
forever ago talking about Ray apps like
I mean easily over 18 months ago where
you could go on Twitter and I tried this
and you were clicking on it and it
wouldn't play on Twitter on Twitter so
it was a clip from IRL on Twitter and it
was like and I tried it on multiple
devices I try to unlike you know on
Wi-Fi off Wi-Fi it would not like it
would start and then it wouldn't and
then it would just go to the spin and it
would lock I think yeah so it was taken
down too which one I think that Darren
Beatty episode was had been taken down
by well we we took it down to put it on
Rumble and it's actually our most viewed
episode ever wow yeah it's got like
eight or nine million views crazy
uh I'll tell you crazy stories tries in
effect in I think it was 2017 I could be
wrong I went to Davos
during the world economic Forum I was in
the peripheral events crypto was a big
component so flew out and I was like all
right recorded some I think I was only
doing like one video per day at that
time so I like recorded a video in
advance flew to Davos
three days of videos that I produced
there are gone oh wow no idea how or why
never received a message or a notice
just on my youtube.com timcast Channel
you can go to the date and there was a I
discovered this years later
when there was a specific video I made
about the case for Bitcoin coming out of
Davos and how all of these you know
worldly Elite types were very interested
in crypto and I was like I want to find
that video that I did because I
interviewed somebody in a bar gone and I
was like where are where are my videos
just gone I used to think this is this
has happened a couple times another time
was I produced a video on something
called the install woman you ever hear
the story
woman in Norway in Bergen Norway it was
a woman who was found up in the
mountains just outside of outside of the
town of Bergen uh the city and she was
dead they said from smoke inhalation
they found a bunch of passports or
something the working theory is that she
was massage and she was tracking down
former Nazis and ending their existence
but this time she did not succeed don't
know for sure exactly if that's true
it's a mystery everyone wonders what
it's all about okay that video is gone
now that one I I can't tell you why and
you know I I thought it was a cool
little mystery ghost story like 10
minute thing and one day I went to to
find it and share with somebody gone
the Davos thing I wonder if that one's a
little on the nose here I am in the
peripheral I didn't go in the event I
had no access to any of that stuff but
outside of the world economic Forum a
bunch of people show up and put on
peripheral parties and events because
they want to basically like suckle the
teeth of influence because everyone's
there yeah and they're hoping that their
peripheral event will get attention and
so I'm there I put three videos together
as I was doing daily videos and they
just got erased
so I'll just put it this way YouTube
very much so secretly takes videos down
there's an individual who is a
whistleblower they called him for the
CIA which resulted in Trump's
impeachment and I don't even know the
rules on saying this guy's name anymore
but you did say it I did say his name
nothing happened yeah maybe maybe that's
why they're they got met but these
videos have also been taken down without
notice Carrick aramella yeah Carrick
Carrick aramella yes good old Carrick
there was a period where even though his
name was being reported widely in the
Press yeah you can say it Rand Paul's
right speaking on the senate floor
unrelated issue mention the guy's name
from a report and YouTube deleted a
C-SPAN clip Fox news clip as well they
were taking this down and they had no
justification there was no rule of
violation it is obvious that there are
intelligence agency assets interlinked
with YouTube the same as Twitter and
Facebook and we know it
we know who's really behind all this Tim
Santa Claus they yeah I was watching
Justice League it was them again I was
watching them I was watching Justice
League and it's this really funny clip I
I started laughing super hard it's the
shows from 2005 but it's Superman being
you know Shazam uh Captain Marvel quits
the team and then Superman's like he's
right and then Batman goes they set you
up Clark and he goes what does it matter
anyway they and then he goes they and
then it plays ominous music and it shows
all the like Justice League looking at
each other it's funny because they is a
reference to the powerful establishment
the corporate Elites the wealthy Elites
but the media for some reason has been
desperate to turn it into specifically
Jewish people so it's like when we when
when we say colloquially they they will
try to claim you're talking about it's
like I'm usually talking about like oil
companies and and Banks you know well
it's contextual as well like right for
example you were just talking about
Davos so in this case you'd obviously be
referring to the world economic Forum
having some kind of joint at the hip
behind the scenes relationship with the
leaders of YouTube so it makes sense for
you to say they and that's well no I
don't think well because it's so much
longer to be able to say that I think
intelligence agencies I think we'll talk
about the the Davos clip specifically I
still think that's U.S intelligence
agencies I will say that I know for a
fact the U.S intelligence agencies have
been very very interested in Bitcoin and
continue to be from from even back when
I was still serving to way into the
future and I had interviewed some
prominent figures in the political space
and without warning without a strike
without an email the videos were taken
down so I wonder if they were like yo we
don't want that person on camera they
shouldn't have done that what do we do
well the video's been publicly viewed by
50 000 people
if we give a strike it's going to make
some waves and we don't want it to
happen so just wait a little bit remove
it without saying anything and it's gone
that's a great it's like stealth editing
yup going into and so with the thousands
of videos we've produced the thousands
of videos daily wire I bet daily wire
doesn't even know the videos that were
taken down because how often are you
going back you know or are you looking
at your total number of videos I mean
it's just you know you're you're
churning out content constantly you're
not like sitting there looking at hey
I'm missing five videos you know yeah I
think the daily wire guy this thing is
like personal uh after like what was a
month ago Matt Walsh got demonetized and
then they went we're officially going to
Twitter I think Matt wall show is not
officially on Twitter that is what the
home of the Matt Walsh show so people at
Google understand the people with daily
wire have no loyalty to Google and
they're like all right these guys are on
their way out anyway I mean you're
seeing and that there that is a broader
story right so you are seeing right now
a broader Showdown because Elon is has
certainly been making some
overtures suggesting that he might get
into the online video
uh Market Marketplace that he might get
into this the Periscope they're talking
about bringing that back he's looking at
different ways to monetize uh Twitter so
if Twitter video people posting Twitter
could potentially be something but also
YouTube is is facing a ton of
competition for rumble right now and
they're starting to feel the heat
they're absolutely starting to eat I
mean it's crazy when you look at some of
these Rumble videos and they have
massive viewership thousands of live
viewers yeah tens of thousands of views
per video and even the videos we put up
get decent amount of hits in the tens of
thousands and that's something we've not
seen any rival be able to pull off until
now we've um so we just on on human
events so we just took my Daily Show and
we were switched it to a live format in
the afternoon now 2PM hey check it out
and we we noticed immediately like a
tenfold increase in our Rumble numbers
just overnight
um the people love it they say like it's
it's a little bit more in the mix you
know it's live so people like that
format but suddenly all of a sudden I
think Rumble it's you know you know and
look like you know I mean I love the
guys at Rumble but I'm sure that they
are giving more priority to live video
because they realize that's a capability
they have that they need to have if they
want to compete against YouTube twitch
Etc everything that's out there yeah I
think if you make internet videos that
you should probably be backing them up
on across multiple platforms I used to
think like all my stuff's on YouTube
it's safe now intensity
yeah unfortunately well especially after
going back and taking you know old
content down for for new rules you know
as they become more insane things that
you made years ago maybe violating
things that they've now decided uh
you're not allowed to say yep and
they'll retroactively give you a strike
and delete your channel it's insane and
guess what you know Elon Musk can't just
swing in and buy every platform out
there I mean I wish but no it's not
gonna happen the strike thing feels very
weird that they struck the channel for
something that happened a while ago yeah
well the strikes I don't know where the
strikes came from for the daily wire but
so 200 violations and I think let me put
the thread from Jeremy what did he say
over the last few months what will
happen is as a social media admin if you
see an account that's questionable and
you're like I think this violates terms
but it's not overt so I'm not going to
block this thing because you err on the
side of like let it up let it stay up
and then it but it builds and then
you'll start to have this like inventory
of like disputable content from this one
Creator and they'll have like seven
things that they've done where you're
like these are seven questionable things
and then over and over and then all of a
sudden they'll do one that crosses the
line you're like all right all of them
cross the line now so it's not really an
ethical way to do it but that is what
happens it does seem like a good portion
of them are demonetization violations
and so we've gotten our share of those
too
uh I I I I don't think I've gotten
um any hate speech demonetizations it's
usually like graphic it's like oh we
demonetize it because it's adult content
or something it's like showing violence
or or conflict or adult themes
but not for a hateful derogative
derogatory content like they're going
after uh the daily wire we're pretty
religious about not doing that on this
show we will talk with our guests before
we go live about what not to say what
violates YouTube's terms so everyone's
up to speed and we got like a 99
accuracy right that's absolutely not
true Ian on on this show we we we may be
mentioned maybe we may be mentioned to
like one out of 15 guests what YouTube's
rules are which results I want to think
it's more than that yeah and that's why
we end up having to take episodes down
because people think that they they
think this show is like sitting in your
friend's living room having a beer as
opposed to Prime Time cable TV talk or
something like that so I usually tell
people if it does so we used to have a
card that's it like this is what
YouTube's rules are we don't have rules
YouTube does if you want to say these
things and the show gets taken down
understand that's what will happen and
so I try to I try to I try to keep a
balance to it where I'm like I'll tell
people look and you can say whatever you
want if you've come all the way out here
to come on this show and then you want
to say things you know will break the
rules we'll roll our eyes and then the
episode gets taken down so if you don't
care about people seeing the episode
like totally get it
but we stopped showing people YouTube's
rules because they would then
intentionally break them or just only
talk about that and we were like dude we
showed you the YouTube policies not so
that you could sit here and just only
talk about that or to intentionally try
and break the rules so then we're like
okay just like dude don't make allusions
to violence all right and then YouTube
had a rule about the election whatever
in fact most of those rules you're
they're not actually enforceable as long
as it's a debate and not overt but the
reason I push back in because it's
actually very very frustrating that we
don't tell everybody when they come on
what YouTube's rules are and then we end
up having to take episodes down lest we
get suspended for a week yeah sometimes
you'll go three hour or two hours I
guess we do two hours in an hour and 59
minutes of it is totally cool but 30
seconds go by and something gets said
and you're like well that's that's we
were batting 99.98 but you can't trim
episodes you can't trim things out I
don't know why they took your episode
down that we did Brandon no idea they
did not tell me we talked about trans
stuff a lot that night yeah but but
we're not like
you know the one thing I tell people is
try to keep it academic yeah you know
what I mean make make your your
criticisms Fierce and passionate but you
know make them academic and not just
generally trying to insult somebody and
so we're usually fine about it and I
have no idea
sorry to interrupt what is their policy
about uh misgendering
I don't think there is one that you
don't no because I remember we talked a
lot about Dylan Mulvaney in that episode
and you were you know staunchly arguing
that he's a man and we were kind of like
having that discussion and my position
has been on all these episodes we'll see
if they write directly enforce this is
that Dylan is a character like Borat
intentionally insulting women and trans
people yeah and now Dylan has that
statement saying I want to move Beyond
this and be a comedian yeah like it's
very it's very lesbian it's very that's
an old part of this comedy and and
actually that clip was him saying that
he's attracted to uh trans women not
biological females sorry but the clip
was was was was cut off what he was what
Mulvaney was arguing uh to his dad was
that he's attracted to women and his dad
was like oh wow and he was like no trans
women because trans women are women
that's what he was saying not that he
likes females but uh my position has
always been that Mulvaney is in I
believe it's a character intending to
mock trans people like would you guys
find like some some
like Paparazzi was like filing following
around Dil Mulvaney and then found that
you know like a normal life like he
doesn't dress like that or act like that
at all but I I don't I don't necessarily
care to get in all that I will just say
though I'm saying it goes to your point
he's playing Camp that's how he
described it like he's campy you know
yeah and you look at like Borat as Bruno
yeah was like a fake gay guy and being
over the top and insulting and you know
Ron Paul got really mad about it that
that that's what I see with Mulvaney but
uh so your episode gets taken down we
have no idea why they won't tell us I
bet that's part of it because that was
right when the Bud Light uh boycott was
kicking off hard and there's a lot of
people talking about Dylan and a lot of
videos got pulled over the course like a
week period or something yeah including
something I think by Michael Knowles
there's a there's something interesting
too when it comes to like Fox News and
other cable networks I have never been
told one time I can't say a thing like
they've never even said hey remember no
swearing I've never even told that
you know you go on you you I don't know
if you've ever you you've done TV hits
and stuff I'd imagine both you guys a
lot yeah have they ever told you like
okay now don't forget when you're on
this is FCC Airwaves so you can't say
these things yeah I've never had that
happen no in Fox Nation you can swear
but the cable network you can't yeah
yeah I've never had someone sit me down
and say anything like that I mean
typically you know you'll be told like
this is what we're going to discuss in
the hit we want to bring you on about
um uh like you know like when I put my
antifa book out there so you know a lot
of TV hits for that so you're gonna talk
with antifa about this you're gonna talk
about this this is the flow it's this
long it's never anything about that
they're never like don't say the f word
tonight no yeah we always tell people
like we try not to swear if you do No
One's Gonna cry about it but there might
be kids listening and they go oh I guess
realistically the onus is on you to
understand FCC regulations if you're
gonna go do a show an FCC guided show I
don't know you really are supposed to
know otherwise you're not going to get
welcome back I was on uh Glenn Beck's
radio show and I said dick I said I was
being a dick and then he was like just a
reminder one FCC Airwaves but you know
anyway and I'm like well radios they've
got a huge yeah can you not say dick
like I I didn't say like male generals I
said like I was being a dick
it's the word literally in that context
means a rude person you know and a few
people have it crossed the line on on
air on Fox and that's been awkward and
those people have not been asked back
there have been a few moments like that
didn't they that have happened who who
was uh
no Matt Walsh or was it was it Matt
Walsh
who was like they stopped booking him
after he he said something on the air oh
yeah yeah he called uh uh he said he
said that um Grant tunberg was
developmentally disabled is that what
happened but that's true
I mean she like she's Autistic or
something and I think he he referenced
this some factual statement and they're
like don't say that about her and it's
like he's like I still remember a couple
years ago when Newt Gingrich was on and
he was talking about the DA's and this
again this was like 2020 and
he's mentioned and oh by the way you
have a lot of these left-wing DA's in
big cities that were funded by George
Soros and the host Cuts him off it's
like whoa whoa we don't want to go there
we don't want to we didn't bring that up
and he's like what do you mean he's the
one who's funding them like I didn't
but it was um yeah he gets cut off the
interview gets stopped he gets like told
off on air and and it's what's Wild
though and you were talking about how
the rules change from day to day now
everybody talks about that it's totally
fine people push it Rhonda sanus talks
about it and he's like a he talks about
Rodney Sanders talks about it Harris
Faulkner constantly okay and
and he's like you know a major candidate
right not not like the leading candidate
but a major candidate and I've never
heard anyone push back on DeSantis to
call him anti-semitic for bringing up
George Soros because I think we've we've
we've breached a point where people
realize that you know now former you
know retired George Soros it's just so
obvious and it's so heavily reported
that you just can't talk about the issue
without referring to Soros DA's it's
just true it's true exactly so I think
it's a great example of showing that if
you keep pushing and you have the truth
on your side right that's the other part
of it you can't just keep pushing you
know for fun remember uh that you're
gonna win remember when a bunch of
people were claiming that there was like
an elite cabal who was trafficking
miners
you know powerful political and
corporate Elites and the media was like
you are crazy you people are nuts and
then Epstein got arrested for it and
then Maxwell is in prison for it and it
was true and Instagram had a massive
Network that was rolled up which which
by the way is amazing to me that we had
this we have this news that comes out
Instagram has this huge pedophile
Network that it's totally available it's
promoted by the algorithm you've got the
Stanford internet research Observatory
you've got
um the University of Massachusetts of
Amherst that puts all did you see have
you seen this thing it's in the Wall
Street Journal they came out and they
were they came up with
they're basically these like dummy
accounts like a brand new account for
Instagram and they would make the
account look like in some instances
they'd make it look like just a general
account and sometimes they'd make the
account look like it that the account
itself was of a minor and then they
would go and interact with accounts that
were offering and they use lots of
different uh
euphemisms and code words for pedophilic
activity child sex child sex trafficking
child trading in some cases menus of
things that you could order specifically
from these accounts and then the next
time they went into Instagram the out
and you went into the search function
the algorithm was feeding it to them yep
wowing it back to them hashtags Etc but
what's Wild to me Wall Street Journal
drops that story and it's just like
everybody kind of shrugs their shoulders
goes on to the next thing like there's
there's massive pedophile networks
operating in the open in the clear on
Instagram they're using all the code
words some quite Infamous and nobody has
anything about it thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time